hello and welcome to this video playing
boozer on goods okay from England okay
anyway so um what am I going to do here
via Kings onion let's do something else
I want to play something interesting you
get that okay I think your white can
take gameplay night before that some
principled line and she does that right
that's very boring
I think this is I mean usually they go
with long castles in this position right
and he didn't do that anyway so let's
think about it a little bit what's going
on here actually if he goes is Queen age
six of Fred's
a little bit yeah mmm yeah but I always
have Queen eight five it would probably
play some g3 or e3 or whatever it's not
very exciting really but why does some
maybe still slightly for choice huh yeah
I wonder if some aged voice is really is
it possible into him I was thinking
about b6 and Bishop d7 but I would like
to have Queen a5 him in this position so
that age for Queen a5 is a little bit a
little bit of a stopper mmm so he allows
the Queen and let's do that let's trade
Queens it doesn't do it okay it's
probably probably not a bad choice
sorry a4 really that's odd that's really
odd why do you do that weakening the
position that really weakens the
position quite a bit okay so I'm just
ready to take the knight now this is
where I go to e6
okay let's try to be a little bit
annoying there
ninety-five would threaten that
threatens b5 it's a very it's a cheap
trick right
but the night wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait I could go to
85 but what is doing there really this
one let's do this one quickly played
yeah I thought the night is not bad on
c5 you know long-term long-term I don't
know if there is long-term him because
he's now starting now he's starting to
play aggressively
all of a sudden yeah it's dangerous
hmm what is he doing him such I mean
okay maybe maybe he gets undirected tack
yeah that's it's possible but doesn't
feel like this should be be happening so
here where to put this rook c7 or
something I don't I'm not happy that he
takes this but I cannot make a sacrifice
out of it that that won't work yeah it
will take I think I'm okay yeah
absolutely but the Queen only five that
cannot be attacked you should be fine
really
maybe King g7 was a clever more clever
move water may be the only thing I
really dislike I said rook on d7 and
that's it's not really well positioned
[Music]
now Luke hh8 will come with the tempo
queen g3 the nice little threat okay
yeah my rook cannot move that is the
thing ready anyway
efore is under attack
I get to take a fork then beehive will
become an option again at the time is
not good yeah 15 seconds 15 seconds
you know expected to smooth
as to us to try for Luke d8 okay
yeah I get to h8 and the tech on h2 is
this kind of waffle
okay and now this one rookie one yeah
it's kind of a shame that this crap
still hold somehow
White's position is just totally
unorganized and still I'm not winning
shoot
now the time situation is awful really
can't believe that I'm not winning here
really unbelievable it still holds the
stuff
six seconds
you know taking a draw there suggested
witness of course now that must be it
must have been a win somewhere with
White's position in shambles iam I obey
I had to clock down to nothing and
nothing is not enough a km night it was
a bit of it it's a bit of a spoilt
forward line iam with Bishop f6 giving
just leading to all the trades this the
screen takes I mean okay it's just equal
right but it's kind of an exciting if
you cannot do much with black so yeah
tonight c3 is probably a good choice
there I don't think white can hope for
anything here with two with two minor
piece of pieces trade it is so certainly
fine yeah if Weiss you know it's very
ugly move but maybe it's okay stop b5 ok
d5 that's interesting that's not I did
not think about this move at all yeah
it's kind of this is somewhat desirable
really because now we get this this
trait the sequence of trades and he I'm
definitely okay yeah it was a good
alternative I didn't see it again now
this b5 idea comes into play but he has
he has this active approach and six
stopping everything and this is a really
debatable thing here five because white
is basically kicking a structure down
the drain you just say okay I'm going to
check made you somehow and then I doubt
that this is such a great approach I get
the Queen to e5 maybe here King g7 is
better
I have it still this control gauge 3 all
right even though they have to know 95
is strong this is important now the
Queen doesn't get there so I have to go
to e5 so I played the right move get
this one
and now the Dyke step by step it went
down down the drain for white but I
couldn't couldn't win it
yeah maybe yeah crimping engine just
wants to take only forward isn't that
bad I mean this is bad right for white
stone what I'm doing it's not too bad
g-form where's the wind I need a window
just take on G form this is actually
strong yeah because I'm threatening what
am i threatening actually not much but I
just get I just take it back right I was
thinking I should have something I
should have been made and it's good I
think for me it's kind of a miracle that
there isn't isn't more but it did hold
him this stuff really holds looking for
specular no I had no time right Andrew
Brooksie for what either the g3 is
saying okay no that wasn't that wasn't
possible for me to spot here who p3 was
winning for white I mean he was blitzing
the same all the same and that his city
there's no wind checking with two two
okay I had this one didn't consider that
and then take h3 somewhere lucky this
and that that I probably would have won
somehow even with no time but okay now
yeah yeah we we had this repetition yes
a bit bit of a spit of a city game but I
had did I have a clear wind and not
really not that I think it's kind of
strange I mean okay the engine says that
this wins but it's not like completely
clear how they are probably just scream
just the attack will probably win but I
thought yeah but it should also win but
it didn't somehow okay anyway I hope you
enjoyed the game thanks for watching